take off your wig you big take off your
way i don't need to take
it is a wig oh my god that's
embarrassing
leukemia do you have cancer oh my
god do you have cancer you were such a
loser you're wearing away cause you're
bald you're fat you're ugly you look
deformed you're poor and you have
counts or no hair and your wigs crooked
by the way fix that
so what's it like having [ __ ] cancer
and having to wear
wigs well it's great because
people give me money you ever had a good
house party
you know when you wake up and you and
you go through the house and you're like
what the [ __ ] is all this
i feel like i just walked into a giant
mess and i don't even remember what
happened bottles everywhere you don't
even remember people pass down the
corner you don't know
and then there's just this girl in the
corner screaming oh my god do you have
cancer
what a loser oh my god were you just
shot seven times fifty cent
wow you're such a goofball oh my god are
you literally about to have your last
breath
oh my god you're going to hell you're
such a loser do you know where i'm going
no me neither oh my god are you dead
you're such a [ __ ] loser oh my god
are you
are you just lifeless right now what a
loser
oh my god let me check your twitter oh
my do you have more
followers than me oh my god yeah yeah
and you're like who are you and she's
like i live here you're like did you
sign a lease last night
what happened all this this is a giant
mess
that's someone that has nothing to say
people pay you
to be ugly and bald no people
pay me because i'm dying you're such a
[ __ ]
loser basically you're getting a welfare
for special needs
so people give you money to go away
because they don't want to deal with you
i guarantee you a lot of people will pay
money for you to disappear as well yeah
people give you money to be
plastic and to go off on people
is that what it is no i'm not putting
this on my video i'd get canceled
i'm never gonna get caught my supporters
will never know that i
i just want to appreciate that she was
just like y'all are never gonna find me
and the internet was like
you've activated my trap card just
smash that and how about oh no reverse
uno reverse
uno reverse plus four plus four plus two
plus two plus one
uno out that's what happened people say
michael jordan's the goat no the
internet's to go
undefeated any people that has a
following
are being followed by people that want
to dox them
that want to expose them yes you get a
lot of love from people
you get money and stuff but there's some
people there's a small faction of these
people
are just waiting for you to [ __ ] up and
jump on that and pounce on you like a
bunch
of starving hyenas being a fan is
actually a spectrum
you got the fans that are you know hey
good looking out i like what you do and
they're gonna
you know they're gonna recognize and be
like hey keep on doing your thing
and they're gonna leave it at that
there's a crazy crazy fan i want to send
you news and the crazy crazy fans that
are fans they do not like you
but they're still fans remember that
girl every time she was
jumping on saying i hate preach you know
your friend
my what it's your friend my what your
friend
my what it's your friend you better take
that back
no then i don't know what you talking
about
but that but yeah that person that was
going going like oh yeah i like the duel
but i don't like preach
why are you are on on every video then
commenting and bashing there's a plenty
of them that's like i really hate you
guys
of course you're gonna say some dumb
like that and they're fans because they
stay there to watch
if you watch someone first fall or you
watch someone for his rise
you're still a fan and yes people can
dox you so i mean then they should just
yell at the girl for another like 10
minutes and then eventually what ends up
happening is that she falls asleep
this is a whole other topic but it's a
genre where
where people pay money to watch people's
street like sleep
so they stream themselves sleeping and
people are paying money to watch
which is supremely creepy i remember one
time there was a girl who was sleeping
and she had 400 000 people watching her
man you know those people who said bro
when you sleep you lose
when you snooze you lose not this
you snooze you cash in
every minute you sleep it's a minute
that you could have been making money
and twitch streamer just like
bro that's crazy but people do that so
anyways while she was sleeping
people were watching her and then her
father whom she lives with was having an
argument with her sister
and personal information was leaked
which therefore led to
to them finding out where they lived dox
them where they work
and then basically as a result her
father lost his
job because the docs they sent the video
of her saying all this stuff to the
father's company
which got him fired so then he got rid
of her and said you have to move out
right now
and at that point i think that's when
like the whole police thing happened
yes i need you at my house i'll be home
in an hour you better not be there i'm
trying to delete i can't delete it
i was sleeping i was sleeping i didn't
know you were screaming
it doesn't matter you stopped
she's more concerned about maintaining
the interaction with her audience and
like
adding them to the drama than having a
dialogue with her dad
listen i don't know what kind of mental
issues this girl's got
i don't know how much therapy she needs
but bruh what's that movie with
uh jim carrey it's a mask no every
mask the truman show
it's it's just a movie where he's born
and everything around him is all a tv
show so everybody watches him
in 24 7 but he doesn't know that he's
he's being watched but it's like kind of
that thing but they know and they want
to entice that
she's filming everything the social
media is that
is the second step of the reality tv
is as the second step is the second step
is
filming everything like that i think
people value their online relationships
a lot more than their real life
relationships or feel very like close
it's one of those weird things why i
always have like a weird thing with fans
even
you know where i'm like i don't feel
connected to you guys
but i recognize that a lot of you feel
connected to us yes because you
see us every day you know when and when
we were
in confinement the first time we were
posting every day we were part of some
people's routine
right right but we're part of yours but
you're not part of ours
which is why it's always weird to be
like this is what's going on i just
can't see myself doing that
the people and i know some of you guys
feel like yo we should but i'm like
no we don't have to i don't feel that
connection to y'all and it's not to be
like downplaying y'all or insulting it's
nothing like that it's just
the people around me know me the people
that i need to tell are the ones who are
always gonna know
i feel like people like this have a
disconnect where they don't they have no
ability to separate their online
relationships or
their interactions there with real life
and and
i think it has a very negative impact on
them as individuals
where her relations with her dad she
doesn't care about it but the fans is
more yeah
i mean that's that's the weird part the
priority is all messed up
it just cost me my job get the house
like telling me to leave right now or he
will like hurt me
my like my dad wants me to leave right
now i
like i don't have a chance to move i
have no internet he is saying that if i
don't leave that i will be like he
he he is going to hurt me
there's a lot to unpack here what else
is there to say that
she's for the streets she's the whole
street she's the whole streets she's the
whole block
she's the whole house party mess it's
crazy
it's a dumb we don't have enough memory
on this [ __ ] memory card
to cover all the problems that are in
here no no it's crazy you need 10
30 therapists to study this book
absolutely this is some crazy crazy
it goes deep there's levels levels she
does
does not care there's so much things
that are you know she doesn't care about
their family doesn't care
i mean you know you're saying that you
said in one of the videos that you know
you don't want to be like you're not an
armchair or therapist or whatever and
stuff and you don't want to deem someone
a narcissist and stuff like that
but rough no still i won't bruh
this is deep there's a lot to unpack in
this and you know i've been sent that
video so
they wanted us to comment on it it's
like there's there's too much
yeah there's too much and beyond that
also it's like what else is there to
take away other than this is like one of
the most
self unself aware people you could come
across
one and two because her values and her
hierarchy of values is so [ __ ] up
the things that she prioritizes doesn't
make any sense no and it's not like
she's apologized since like if you watch
her most recent streams like
she's still on she's doing her thing
she's still on that
she's still doing it and she's doubling
tripling quadrupling down despite losing
her access to her family so
you know for me it's just like
that's a life of misery that you guys
are watching right there it's not like
she has a lot of subscribers either
she's got like two thousand
no that's not no no diddy she got two
thousand yeah
no yeah yeah unless
all that for 2 000 people yep
yep item so like i said man
this is one of those situations where
i'm just like i'll wash my hands of this
one i don't even want to unpack this
uh but if you've got stuff you want go
for it well you touched a bit on it when
you said that you know we had a
they have a relationship with us that we
don't have so whenever i get stopped in
the street and people are like
hey what's up and yelling in my face and
i i'm not at the same level of litmus
that you are
i'm like yeah hi and i look like i don't
know you but
that's because i don't know you that's
one thing and broadcasting
every detail of your life like that is
just not healthy
there's some things that people are
going to try to do and try to want to do
for i don't know what reason
but it's not something that i do
sometimes i get on lives and people
people asking hey show us a picture of
your wife i'm like why would you want to
know that
why like there's some things that are
good that are better left and i there
that you don't need to know
you don't need to know every detail of
of the people that you follow is live
this is like the ultimate form of
self-centeredness
yes good luck to you my dear because you
have a hard life ahead of you so this
just all i got
that's it her and soho carrot
god bless oh yeah it's a different level
but
it's the same direction so i was
watching that video and i was i kept on
on on thinking about what you were
saying yep
internet ruined a whole generation i was
like yo that's just the proof of it
and there's much there's more people
like that that just do
things for clout i mean i wonder is that
the case
or is it also possible that to a lesser
degree people who were
self-centered and not self-aware now or
just have a platform to showcase that
behavior
fair you know what i mean maybe maybe
you know we had we had movies about
bimbos like this back in the day too
true
that were in high school and stuff like
that who would do stuff and talk like
this true
yeah the only difference now is i got
social media so it just seems like it's
more in your face all the time oh yeah
exactly you know so that's and you know
the algorithm works in such ways that
people love messiness like this they
can't help it so
yeah i wonder which is where it's her or
the people watching it to interference
entertainment i mean i don't know
they're both part of the ecosystem
people are encouraging and watching the
messiness
and then she's engaging in the messiness
so yeah
it's like who's worse the people buying
the weapons or the people selling them
you know what i mean
right it's like the people buying the
bombs or the people selling them i don't
know
which one's worse i don't know if you
can really say which way
either way yeah but you know i just
don't like messiness like that so that's
a pass for me
that's too much oh well that's all for
me man all right tell us what you guys
think in the comments below
[Music]
foreign
more than one